ahora somos doble de francia más de
veinte años de carrera siete álbumes de
estudio y 45 países visitados de bing es
la mayor banda francesa de reggae y
dancehall la clásica historia de un
grupo de amigos que querían hacer música
pero que siempre se mantuvieron
independientes y que forjaron su éxito
con el voz a voz y con su energía en el
escenario los conocimos en bogotá justo
antes de lo que iba a ser su primer
concierto después de dos largos años de
pandemia en el jamming festival un
evento cancelado 24 horas antes de la
apertura de sus puertas pero también
quiso su regreso a los escenarios unos
días después durante un concierto
gratuito ante 8.000 personas y junto a
otros artistas internacionales porque
esa es la esencia de tuvimos una
reputación basada en el directo bien
compartido
de bing gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en france 24
no es su primera vez en colombia ni en
latinoamérica jan ha estado varias veces
en méxico donde grabaron una versión
acústica de la conexión al exilio fue
precisamente porque este texto cobraba
sentido en ese lugar y así es que nos
gusta traer imágenes al menos en
nuestras giras anteriores era algo que
hacíamos regularmente ya que viajábamos
mucho por áfrica por sudamérica por
diferentes lugares del mundo
y si encima podemos traer imágenes con
música para compartirlo con nuestro
público francés que no se da cuenta de
que en realidad viajamos tanto por todo
el planeta y es cierto que en el caso de
la canción exilio en un país como méxico
desató la cuestión de la inmigración que
siempre ha sido muy querida en nuestras
letras
y sienten que tienen un público aquí en
américa latina cuál es su relación con
este continente
y es una locura porque la primera vez
que vinimos fue a méxico pero incluso
aquí bogotá vinimos al festival rock al
parque
el parque ante 60.000 personas y no lo
esperábamos
luego tocamos en un club llamado casa
babylon se llenó fue una locura luego
volvimos a colombia para el jamming
festival fue una locura y cuando vamos a
argentina también es una locura así que
sentimos que hay una conexión real en
primer lugar la gente conoce el reggae
francés lo cual es bastante sorprendente
para nosotros
porque cuando vamos a los sound systems
después tocan canciones de otros grupos
franceses
y eso es realmente este ambiente del
reggae que es muy querido para nosotros
que hemos llamado desde que empezamos la
banda con nuestro adn es internacional
tienen letras en tres idiomas francés
inglés y que avileños son una banda
francesa pero con una verdadera mezcla
de orígenes entre todos los miembros y a
menudo tratan temas internacionales
también cantan sobre la migración el
mestizaje el racismo los conflictos la
resistencia es esto lo que querían desde
el principio esta identidad tan
internacional no se fue construyendo con
el tiempo
para construir
entre nosotros no los dijimos vamos a
elegir un beninés 2 kábilas griego y un
español español no existe sino de hecho
santa tiene nuestra ciudad ya es así es
decir que incluso se puede decir que
francia es así eso es lo que iba a decir
que esa nación es así pero que también
lo es francia e incluso el mundo porque
ahora las fronteras son diferentes ya no
estamos en
1907 que desde el principio sin saberlo
llevábamos esta cosa internacional en
nosotros y la reivindicamos verás
nuestro primer disco se llamaba
diversidad mientras que nosotros
simplemente hablábamos de nuestra
diversidad de nuestra pequeña ciudad de
sant etienne entendíamos que
representábamos eso y que nuestro
público era así que era colorido
mezclado de diferentes orígenes étnicos
y sociales eso es realmente algo que
siempre hemos llevado desde el principio
y de hecho muy naturalmente cuando
empezamos a exportar fue primero en
europa en grecia en portugal en italia
etcétera nos dimos cuenta de que esta
mezcla que estaba en nuestro música se
entendía en todas partes
por otro lado también es una de nuestras
luchas
es decir no es sólo reivindicar la
diversidad es que siempre intentamos
decir mira no es complicado podemos ser
de diferentes orígenes sociales como
dice el ethnikos lo que quieras somos
muy diferentes en la banda sin embargo
es muy fácil hacer cosas juntos sólo hay
que escucharse y dejarse hablar y eso es
algo que siempre hemos querido
reivindicar
[Música]
no
me escucharon
en el momento de grabar esta entrevista
a la guerra en ucrania lleva más de tres
semanas la situación de los artistas
ucranianos en el país los debates sobre
el boicot o no de los recursos son
cuestiones que les apelan son cuestiones
que están sobre la mesa en el medio
artístico en francia no
es que no son cuestiones nuevas tengo la
impresión de que durante los 20 años que
llevamos tocando siempre ha habido
eventos así en todo el mundo nosotros
como artistas siempre llevamos el mismo
mensaje
esta guerra en ucrania es de una
violencia absoluta es desafortunada creo
que nuestras voces estoy hablando de
nuestras voces como artistas y como
todos los artistas son muy importantes
los artistas a poco cuando nos dicen que
boicoteemos a los artistas rusos me
parece una estupidez hay muchos de estos
artistas que no defienden a putin y creo
que son precisamente las voces de los
artistas las que marcan la diferencia en
un momento en el que todo el mundo está
bloqueado cada uno en su campo cada uno
tiene sus convicciones todo el mundo es
muy violento con el otro y creo el matiz
la reflexión también viene de la cultura
así que creo que es absurdo decir que
debamos boicotear a los artistas rusos
especialmente en cuanto a nosotros sería
un poco fácil criticar los artistas
rusos quiero decir a ser un país donde
podemos abrir la boca
allí no es la misma limonada cuando se
critica el gobierno hay una novela y
contra la libertad de expresión que voy
a llevar a la gente a la cárcel hasta 15
años exactamente no vamos a dar grandes
lecciones desde aquí al fin y al cabo
como él dice en los 20 años que llevamos
en el escenario hay guerras por todas
partes
hay bombardeos por todos lados es cierto
que hay una proximidad geográfica por lo
que es llamativo y es terrible pero
vamos a tocar para ellos
es decir cuando hablamos de bombas en
nuestras canciones da igual que sea en
ucrania que en siria o en yemen luego
posee su lado nosotros nos duele ver la
gente así de verdad
y sinceramente y cuando hablamos de
abrir nuestras puertas a los que sufren
nos referimos también a los ucranianos a
los yemeníes a los sirios a todas esas
personas que huyen de esta miseria
sevilla
antes hablabas de viajar hemos viajado
por todas partes por áfrica hemos
viajado por méxico hemos viajado por
rusia hemos tocado en rusia sabemos por
qué la gente
siempre decimos basta de historias sobre
los inmigrantes no es normal que
tengamos que apoyar a asociaciones como
eso es mediterráneo
no tendría que ser así debemos ayudar a
las personas que huyen porque la guerra
está en todas partes y pactos así que sí
debemos acoger a los ucranianos todos
los que huyen debemos encontrar
soluciones para todos
[Música]
de witte
spanair
[Música]
por visibles pues está informando con el
lema y matar
[Música]
ah
dios no va nada bueno hemos hablado de
lo que critican pero también plantean
muchos valores en sus canciones sobre
todo el tema de la herencia que parece
ser algo que les importa mucho la última
canción que me recuerda esto es atagua
je son con o sin razón pero hay muchas
otras que voy a quieren dejar en la
música qué valores quieren transmitir a
las futuras generaciones de artistas
si ya la imagen de lo que somos perdura
es decir aquí estamos un grupo con
muchos orígenes que fue capaz de
trabajar en conjunto que fue capaz de ir
más allá de nuestras diferencias para
crear algo nuevo algo que nos pertenece
si podemos dejar eso como huella y luego
simplemente dejar buenos temas con
buenos mensajes sí y luego creo que en
cierto modo de nuestra carrera nos
liberaremos de los medios de
comunicación
es decir que al principio no sabíamos
muy bien cómo funcionaban las cosas así
que pensamos que era absolutamente
necesario tener entrevistas
para obtener reconocimiento y
reconocimiento eso es
y cuando nos dimos cuenta de que de
hecho el público nos apoyaba no es una
crítica a los medios de comunicación
realmente no nos importa pero creo que
somos una banda que no desempeña ningún
papel
no pretendemos ser los abanderados de
nadie solo somos amigos que quieren
hacer música que quieren viajar que
quieren expresarse un poco
y defender todos estos valores y eso es
todo
la 'celebrity' y de hecho podemos buscar
la fama creo que nos ha ayudado y nos
han salvado de muchos errores dijo a
menudo cuando la gente nos pide consejo
para las bandas jóvenes etcétera para mí
eso es lo principal
haz lo que quieras en realidad
y sé tú mismo tú ya sabes en realidad
haz lo que te apetezca y de hecho creo
que es esto lo que nos ha sostenido
durante 20 años divertirnos entre
nosotros y seguir adelante si podemos
dejarlo como imagen está bien y antes
del próximo disco que va a salir en en
septiembre
su último álbum millones y también el
álbum en acústico todavía están
disponible
muchas gracias gracias gracias
nunca
a todos
[Música]